(bright music)
All season long, we're highlighting hometowns
all across the country because there's no place like home.
Next up, it's Seattle, Washington,
where Marlie and Anthony Love call home.
The Loves loves Seattle,
and I have a feeling we're about to also, watch this.
Hey, Drew, it's Anthony and Marlie,
and we're in front of Pike Place Market
located in our hometown of Seattle, Washington.
Drew, we love Seattle so much,
not just because of the great scenery and great coffee
but there's some places that mean so much to us personally.
So, come with us and let us show you around.
(upbeat music)
We are at the iconic Space Needle,
a signature staple for the Seattle skyline.
Of course, it's iconic, but it's personal for us
because on our first trip to Seattle in 2015,
this was the spot
when we decided that we were gonna move to Seattle.
And now it just represents the love
that we have for this city.
Well, Drew, that's just a snapshot
of this beautiful city of Seattle.
We hope you love it as much as we do,
we can't wait for you to come visit, see you soon.
(bright music)
Hi Drew, it's Chef Nik,
I'm here at Arizona's Family Studios in Phoenix, Arizona.
One of the things I love about my hometown of Phoenix
is it has 365 days of sunshine.
Come on, let me show you.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to Tempe Beach Park.
You have people that are riding their bikes, people walking,
skateboarding, paddleboarding.
At nighttime, there's concerts,
so it's a really happening spot.
(bright music)
We're here at the beautiful Desert Botanical Garden,
I love this place because I used to take my daughter here
when she was little.
They have the most beautiful butterflies
and they have over 50,000 types of plants.
We are here with Dana, the director of marketing,
Dana, can you tell us a little bit about
what makes this place so special?
The garden is just such an icon in the valley.
We're filled with all these beautiful desert plants
from around the world,
plus we have the most beautiful exhibitions
and events throughout the year,
it's just a great place to immerse yourself
in nature and explore the desert.
And now we're here at Chic Chef Marketplace.
I create every single product that is on the shelf.
Not only is it created by me, it's created with love.
It's just a beautiful snapshot
of this beautiful town of Phoenix.
I can't wait you to come and visit yourself.
See you soon.
Hey, Drew, I'm Will Grimes,
this is my business partner, Eli Schmidt,
we are the Mile High Property Brothers.
Today, we're at CBS 4,
we're gonna be showing you everything we love about Denver,
more importantly, what you might not know about Denver,
but it's work hard, play hard here.
What do you love, Eli?
Guys, people in Denver, we love to work hard,
we love to get after our business,
but even more so, we love to have fun.
We fricking love it here.
So we're gonna check out what a typical day
for a Coloradan might look like.
(bright music)
Here we are at Washington Park
in the heart of Denver.
This park, guys, is centered around
one of the biggest focuses that locals have in Denver
and that's fitness.
There is no lack of things to do here.
The Dairy Block is often not known from even the locals
so it is a true secret spot,
it is what they call an activated alley or a micro district.
They've actually taken what was a normal alley,
just between two big buildings,
and they put restaurants and shops,
some interactive artwork,
on the weekends, you can find farmer's markets,
you can find bingo, karaoke,
all sorts of cool stuff out here.
What a pleasure to show you guys
everything Denver means to us.
Guys, Denver's fit, it's active, we're progressive,
we're about our business,
but we're about our food and our fun as well.
So if you're thinking about coming out this way,
or at least paying us a visit, make sure you reach out.
See you guys next time.
(bright music)